oh
uh
california
okay
like
right
i know
out there
um
a lot of them come around
i don't know is this hand on chairs
which
this
um
um
[Music]
um
um
foreign
yes
so
okay
why
um
okay
she's great
um
um
apology
um
uh
um
um
okay
okay
uh uh
yes
[Music]
okay
and country have been anxiously awaiting
the completion of our investigation to
the death
of miss ariana taylor prior to this
announcement
i spoke with miss palmer brianna
taylor's mother
uh to share with her the results from
the creator
many of you know that i had the
opportunity last month
to meet in person with her and other
members of miss taylor's
family
someone they love is no longer with them
there's nothing i can offer today to
make the takeaway
and heartache this family is
experiencing
as a result of losing a child
a niece a sister and a friend
but i can provide today on facts
my office has worked long and hard to
recover
analyze and scrutinize
accepting this case in mid-may i urge
everyone to listen
today to not lose sight the fact that
life
has been lost in tragedy under
any circumstances the decision before my
office
as a special prosecutor in this case was
not to decide
the loss because taylor's life was a
tragedy
the answer to that question is
unequivocally
yes there's no doubt that this is a
blood wrenching emotional case pain that
many people
are feeling is understandable
i deeply care about the value of the
satanic
human life protection
in this case human life is lost
i cannot forget that my job
as the special prosecutor in this space
was to put
emotions aside investigate the facts
to determine if criminal violations of
state law
resulted in the loss of miss taylor's
life examining
the actions of sergeant jonathan
mattingly
detective brett hankinson and detective
miles cosgrove
three officers buying their weapons
working with our federal partners on
this case was determined that while we
would share
information to advance our respective
investigations
we must also maintain some level of
separation
investigation
destination focused on the events that
took place in miss taylor's apartment
on march 13th in the month since taking
this case
a dedicated team of prosecutors and
investigators
of combined career experience
[Music]
tireless world these men and women are
true public servants who for months have
shown up
every day for desire for one thing
and that is to seek the truth we decided
while
we would examine materials gathered by
lmpd's public
integrity unit we would need to conduct
our own
independent investigation and start from
scratch
in the interest of thoroughness fairness
and finding the truth there was no video
or body camera footage of the officer's
attempted execution of a search warrant
at miss taylor's
residence video footage begins at the
point that area patrol officers
arrive at the location therefore
the sequence of events from march 13th
had to be pieced together
through ballistics evidence 911
calls police radio traffic and
interviews
we utilized information from the
kentucky state police
local medical examiners as well as
working with the fbi
crime lab in quantico to secure a
trajectory analysis
and ballistics report a team conducted
interviews in this case spent thousands
of hours
examining all of the available evidence
we concluded our last
interview well in this case this past
friday
again our grand jury presentation monday
as long as the case is making afraid
can only speak in general terms about
our independent
investigation and findings as the
prosecutor
i'm prohibited by the kentucky rules of
professional conduct
making public comments that could in any
way prejudice this case
as it moves forward each state has
different rules about what prosecutors
can and cannot say the kentucky rules
are clear
that i'm prohibited in making comments
that could sway public opinion
of heightened public combination of
those
involved in the case these are crucial
rules to ensure
being processed under the constitution
the prosecutors prematurely release
information
about the case of the public and you can
risk justice
by poisoning the jury violating the
accused
rights to a fair trial and even
jeopardizing
the final verdict the success of our
legal system
is predicated on the principle that the
accused
is innocent until proven guilty
despite passions opinions the desire for
every detail
to be known
justice must be done in the early
morning hours of march 13th
officers from lmpd executed a search
warrant
at 5303 springfield drive
part four this was miss brianna taylor's
residence
the officers
serving this specific search warrant
the scope of our investigation did not
include the obtainment
of that warrant by lmpd's criminal
interdiction
division federal law enforcement
partners
are conducting that investigation
sergeant mattingly and detectives grove
and hinkinson
had never known involved in the
preceding investigation
or payment of the search warrant
they were called into duty as extra
personnel
to effectuate the service of the search
warrant they only had
information conveyed to them during
their
prior briefing evidence shows
that officers both knocked and announced
their presence at the apartment the
officers statements about their
announcement
are corroborated by an independent
witness
who was near in proximity to apartment
four
in other words the war was not served
as a no-knock warrant the officers were
unable to get anyone to answer or open
the door
to apartment four the decision was made
to breach the door after reaching the
door
sergeant mattingly was the first and
only officer
to enter the residence sergeant
mattingly identified
two individuals standing beside one
another at the end of the hall
male and female in his statement
he says that the male was holding a gun
arms extended
and the shooting stands sergeant
mattingly
saw the man's gun fire heard a boom
and immediately knew he was shocked as a
result of feeling heat
in his upper thigh kenneth walker fired
the shot from kid sergeant matty
there's no evidence of course sergeant
natalie was hit by friendly fire
from
the ballistics report shows that the
round that struck sergeant mattingly was
fired from a nine-millimeter
handgun the lmpd officers
fired 40 caliber handguns
sergeant mattingly returned fire down
the hallway are you holding
shot 16 times this all took place
in a matter of seconds just need a ifb
number total
six bullet struck miss taylor right
medical evidence attachment
our team indicates that only one shot
was fatal further
okay some bullets traveled through
apartment four
and into apartment three before some
exited
that apartment at the time three
residents
of apartment three
evidence that any bullets fired from
detective hinkinson's weapon
struck okay we are in taylor ksp
ballistics analysis
did not identify which of the three
officers
fired the fatal shot after receiving
that information i asked the fbi crime
lab to conduct its own analysis
to see if they reach the same results
the fbi ballistics analysis concluded
the fatal shock inspired by the
technical
hey what's up our officers looked at
both how's it going guys
to determine if there were major
differences in the procedures
used by church 1098-7654521
today begins three days of public
morning ruth bader ginsburg casket
arriving
this morning on the steps of the supreme
court well back on capitol hill and the
white house
is highly respected for their work there
was nothing
our investigators point to thank you nor
anything provided by the respective
agents
yeah that directly explains why actually
also there's a little like uh
mixed minus or reverberation in that i
think it is worth repeating again
that our investigation is that in
cosgrove
justice continue their use of force
after having been fired upon
by kenneth walker secondary to this
justification
the ksp and fbi ballistics and analysis
specialization they're telling you
creating a reasonable doubt
in the evidence about who fired the
fatal ship okay
okay just making sure i certainly
understand the public's desire we do
have a hit at uh
many have questioned the length of that
205. no because they're in special
coverage simply put i had to try
every means necessary to determine who
fired the fatal shark
before the investigation wait who's that
pleaded 205
as fresno and special coverage complete
knowledge of all evidence collected in
this case
lawyers with our office special
prosecutions
that presented the findings of our
independent investigation
before a grand jury comprised of
jefferson county residents
beginning on monday and concluding today
fletcher graham kentucky supreme court
says that the grand jury
has publicly justice casket
arriving at the supreme court today
to protect the public against unfounded
criminal prosecutions
casket will be here in public view at
the surrey court
is necessary to ensure that justice is
done both for the victims
and the supreme court different abc
seven hearing the evidence from our team
of prosecutors sorry they're abc seven
eyewitness news
against detective hankinson for three
counts
of wanton endangerment for wantonly
placing
three individuals in apartment three in
danger of serious
physical injury or death
[Music]
up to five years for each count
kentucky law states that a person is
engages in conduct which creates a
substantial
dangerous
however it's important to note that he
is presumed innocent
until proven guilty for the last six
months
we've all heard mention of possible
charges that we brought into space
it's important to understand that all
the charges have been mentioned have
specific meanings
and ramifications critical homicide
encompasses
the taking of a life by another
while there are six possible homicide
charges under kentucky law
these charges are not applicable to the
facts before us
yes our investigation showed the grand
jury agreed
mattingly were justified
in the return of the deadly fire after
having an entire
kennel let me state that again according
to kentucky law
abuse of course by mattingly
to protect themselves this justification
bars us from pursuing criminal charges
in ms brianna taylor's death
truth is now before us the facts have
been
examined the grand jury okay the prize
of our peers
fellow citizens has made a decision
[Music]
that is our responsibility and this will
be done while the fbi continues
its investigation not even i'm not even
kidding it's the light on the court is
also violations
of federal law i know that not everyone
will be satisfied
with the charges reported today my team
set out to invest uh
circumstances surrounding miss taylor's
which one was five five nine isn't it
singular okay they are in special
coverage
kentuckians deserve no less the city of
louisville
deserves no less every person that
reaches it has an idea
of what they think justice is i wrote a
special prosecutor
in this case to set aside everything
outrageous
it's happened before
though we as a community must make
this decision i understand that mr
brianna trainer's death
has become a part of a national story
and conversation we must also remember
the facts and the collection of evidence
in this case
are different than cases elsewhere in
the country
how to feel suggesting they understand
the facts
of this case that they see our community
and the commonwealth
better than we do but they don't
let's not give in to the attempts to
i urge those protesters on the streets
to remember this peaceful protest are
you right
as an american citizen
and destruction and you don't know how
long you're not going to stick i've
spoken with the special fisher
yeah actually in the days leading up to
this okay announcement and i urge them
to do
what is necessary to maintain law yeah
uh
producer says he's trying to get in
touch with our people i guess the desk
or the control room but nobody's
answering
ahead you see you'd be better off as we
pursue this case through the criminal
system
and as well so should he keep calling or
what's that what's a good number of the
healing process
when tragedy occurs okay must mourn
we must also do everything we can
to prevent it from happening again
today they said that no outside calls
are working
announcing that i will create a task
force to review the process basic
process
they don't know when they're going to
get out of reviewing coverage is kind of
up to us
in kentucky the task force will consist
of stakeholders okay
yeah exactly so i would say i guess yeah
if it's if it's still 11
defense on the hour that's fine elected
leaders i'll be issuing an executive
order in the coming days to create this
task force
i believe top to bottom review
of the search warrant process is
necessary
to determine great changes i'll stick
around and if not i understand
establish a special property yeah you
have my word
that i will also vigorously prosecute
the criminal charges
announcement so they're going to hold us
through the team and then
we'll see yeah we'll continue to give
this case
their attention and time
will also continue to support the good
people
their voice isn't heard
[Applause]
[Music]
i choose the side of justice i choose
decide truth i choose the path
okay all right forward you guys still
have our package and everything too so
yep thank you you have that choice as
well
let's cancel livestock thank you
and god bless thank you i'm going to
take some questions
i will get into the specifics of the
makeup of the
grand jury so
based on evidence there's nothing
conclusive to say
that protective hankinson's any
physicalness
get this tailored
and i appreciate those um this is a
tragedy
sometimes the law the criminal law is
not adequate
to respond to a tragedy and i fully
acknowledge that
and i know many that are watching today
the response uh
grand jury proceedings
[Music]
about
is
detective cosgrove and
[Music]
i'll leave it to others to make
determinations uh we have uh
vigorous self-defense laws in this state
and that is something that existed prior
to this case
i'll let others make judgments about
that yes sir
one big question surrounding this case
i've never heard
the officers not announce their presence
talk about the evidence that you bring
to what they did
now yes statements
that were made by officers
there the night or the morning of march
13th
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
was
needed to make their assessment from
their judgments and ultimately their
conclusion
was that the decision needed to be made
to indict
mr england mr cameron mr cameron rick
medina within your times
right here right here hi two questions
for you remember when you said that she
was shot
six times yet her death certificate says
five can you please explain the
discrepancy
and the second thing is uh journalists
in this room myself included
have taken apart that apartment complex
looking for witnesses
to the point that you knew about the
locker room of a dozen witnesses that i
spoke to
only one a man who was directly upstairs
heard them announce
do you think that's a very good in the
middle of the night when somebody is
asleep
for for just one person in a in a
tight-knit apartment block to have heard
that is that a sufficient
way of answering well let me try to
answer your second question first
um your question was is enough
for me i think the more important
question is what was the
evidence provided to the grand jury what
was sufficient for their purposes
they got to hear and listen to all the
testimonies
and made the determination that
detective hankinson was the one that
needed
the death certificate says five uh and
yet you are saying
six today's the first time i'm hearing
six so uh
a bullet um
it might be too generous and an object
that was lodged
into the into one of her feet
and so that is what is being referred to
as the
sixth uh uh i guess projectile
are you going to are you going to
release the pool are you going to
release the full grand jury report
can you say that are you going to
release the full grand jury report
well fighting on my google drive right
now because there is
is
well that is
well again all the evidence
your last question about providing
information
in any investigation criminal
investigation
the best practice and this is whether on
the state or
federal government is to not make too
many specific
comments because do not want to
compromise
that investigation there are also
ethical considerations
as in as investigators and prosecutors
that we're responsible to abide by as
well
some of those obligations continue now
because we have a responsibility to
pursue the prosecution
against detective hankinson uh it is
it's my judgment
uh very early on that we needed to take
this case in the attorney general's
office uh as you know
the lost attorney was conflicted out of
this case because of
another matter that he was pursuing i
could have formed the case out
to another commonwealth's attorney
[Music]
in my judgment uh were needed to uncover
the truth in this case
and one of the reasons the investigation
took something
is because we needed to make sure that
we were doing a thorough
job of
and making sure that all of our people
are confident
uh thorough and fair analysis
uh
that's not my call
do we have a sufficient amount of time
to get ready for a hearing
and when i say we i mean the nominee
as well as the members of the committee
and we didn't i spend a lot of time
to actually allow everyone to have their
safe
and to have their questions answered is
the truth both
orally and right i presented that to the
great uh in the confirmation
and uh i think we have plenty of time do
you worry about
what this could mean for some of your
republican colleagues who are facing
re-election what do you say to people
who say this is just another example of
the black community
i think this year what is specifically
happening
that's long been uh
that of all of our responsibilities
responsible
uh this is one of the most sovereign if
not the most
chief and this is important and uh this
imprisonment
is understanding i understand that as a
black man and we want to do it right
um i'm looking forward to the hearings
i'm going into it i will go into it
prepared i'm looking for someone
of
well i've heard i've heard that my
friend senator schumer was misplaced
um there was not make a lot of arguments
this office didn't go to school
thinking about it and i get it it wasn't
you know uh
first thing on our uh there's a lot of
drama getting to the truth
and there will be a lot of things said
back and forth about who should
what criminal law i i approach it to
respond
in a pretty basic manner and that is
true
that the i've read the constitution i've
read the provisions on filling the
supreme court based on that
i said that repeatedly the constitution
is
unaffected by the electoral calendar
and if the president nominates someone
to fill this vacancy i will vote find it
very hard
judiciary committee and i will vote for
the house
that's the case then why did republicans
hold up merrick garland's nomination
you will have to ask him i didn't ever
make any determination like that you
won't have to ask them
i can only speak every source that we
can but i intend to uh
uncover the president makes a nomination
i intend to vote
and let me assure you um on the
i recognize in my remarks that i
mentioned the fact that
we'll be establishing a task force in
the coming days ahead to look at best
practices for
us so there is a lot
to help
um just wanted to double check um the uh
romance like did the french ever
consider the target with manslaughter
reckless homicide and um
did you anticipate any other charges in
this case i apologize could you
say that a little while i think sure
did grand jury ever consider
manslaughter or reckless homicide or
those kinds of charges um and if not
please explain why do you anticipate any
other charges or are
we is this it i won't get uh into
the specifics again of the the
proceedings themselves are secret but
what i will say
is that our team walked them through
every
homicide offense and also presented
all the information
that was available
to the grand jury and then the grandeur
was ultimately
the one that made the decision about uh
indicting
detective hankinson for wanting
endangerment
i think that in terms of what happened
in the hours of march
in terms of that particular
or specific date and what happened that
night in the apartment
i think it's it is unlikely that there
will be
any additional prosecutions that come
from
that event itself
attorney general um so can you can you
go and
even open
well so as to your first question what i
think
you asked about was um
yes the reports that were provided to us
by the kentucky state police and then
the fbi
as it relates to ballistics so initially
we got the important
kentucky state
about making the determination into that
fatal shot
and so again with the relationships that
we have
with our federal law enforcement
community namely the fbi
i thought it imperative that we utilized
that resource
so they undertook an independent
analysis
and conducted provided a ballistics
report
there was nothing that this team was
able to
it certainly creates some issue
in terms of providing that
injury and providing that with any
subsequent
prosecution and so it was
uh and that information and the
information the facts that were provided
to them
to be uncovered in our investigations
they made the determination
to detect the one that needed to be
united here yes
um so
i speak for the entire department
i know that you said that the
investigation has obviously taken months
and it was presented to the grand jury
monday
can you tell us when did the grand jury
actually how long did they
deliberate did they begin on monday or
did they be in tuesday
and that was it this week correct the
grand jury was presented with the
information today
i want to get into the specifics of when
they began their
refrigerations but i will say
that they started early monday
[Music]
so they heard everything they needed to
hear
we did not hold anything from them
and uh i hope that satisfies your
question
a general can you tell me a little bit
more about this
you know senate president stivers and
representative
scott are introducing uh warrant bills
for the next legislative session
are they going to be on this task force
per chance that will you be taking some
of the information
to work well i i don't want to put
obviously
on this task force and i imagine
some of the policy questions and some of
the policy proposals that have already
been put forward and
put it into the public conversation
but make sure that people recognize that
this task force is being established not
to
demonize
one department or agency i think it's a
healthy thing
for the attorney general
[Music]
about best practices that you can be
utilized
i had a recent conversation with
somebody that said there's always room
for improvement
i think that's important
important job and so it's part of my
role
[Music]
of all sorts of witnesses and
folks and so again all
right yes sir when you look at the
analysis of the path
of the bullets how was it that kenneth
walker who fired the shot at the
officers
was not hit and brianna taylor was hit
so many times
well that's that's part of the tragedy
um but um
the fact that that she was hit
breaks my heart and breaks the
collective heart from
the country
[Music]
of the trajectories themselves two
follow-up questions
of the grand jury and number two you
mentioned that cosgrove fired the fatal
shot but did you clarify um how many
shots
in all that hit this taylor were fired
by
mattingly and how many shots the fitness
team were fired
by cosgo well i see the last question um
inconclusive in terms of
um
the fact that this is perceived so much
i think it would be inappropriate for me
to share the information
about that particular student to the
extent i can
protect
uh
daniel
well
it's to find the truth so uh when
folks from outside of the commonwealth
suggest or make preferences
we can't be in the business i don't
think we want a justice system
that is in the business of fashioning
facts or laws
in particular we have to be in the
business
of presenting the information to the
grand jury
thank you very much sir i wanted to ask
if if you
um you know if you believe personally
that someone should have been charged
with
homicide or one of the similar charges
you know
um and if you think that's true that
happened after
the door opposes not from the door did
they hear an
answer how long did they wait before
everything erupted so both of those
questions please and thank you very much
asked your first question um again this
is about
what the grand jury decided one of the
misconceptions out there is that
the attorney general's office was in the
business of
making charges and that's just simply
not the case under kentucky law
our goal is to present the information
to the grand board
we dispense with that responsibility uh
we did it after a protracted
investigation that uncovered all of the
facts
that was all wrong that was our
responsibility
and we presented everything to the grand
jury for him
making judgment about what to do next
and in this case
in this instance they decided to indict
detective hinkinson
specifics in that particular
yes sir in the beginning you said that
you spoke with
brianna taylor's family today i know you
can't tell us
word for word and what they said to you
but
how was it so my email
but it was a difficult meeting
when i ran for this office uh you know i
ran because i
had some singular ideas in mind
you never know exactly what issues
and it's a very good
and i certainly recognize the
responsibility that i have
to help with the healing process
but also respects our responsibility
as the bible talks about our neighbors
and that we can do so
he can draw a table legacy right
so we'll be covering the overall
city that respects all of our
uh to work together to find common
ground and
provide ways to love one another
and just be with neighbors so that's
what i important
if you all would put on this in a
responsible manner that's what i am for
those that are watching
on television that we all have the
responsibility of coming together
and hopefully we will take that charge
seriously the governor
likes to talk about team kentucky and i
believe
all of thank you and god bless
oh